the queen's statement made it very clear
that you're not going to
hear probably from the palace she wants
to
take this issue in-house deal with it
in private um within the family
so in a way um prince william is going
against his grandmother's wish because
he has come out and said something
but i think he said it because he feels
so strongly
and he felt he had to say it he feels
that he has to defend
his family and that's what he did today
have you spoken to your brother since
the interview
i haven't spoken yet but i will do and
and can you just let me know is that the
royal family a racist family sir
we're very much not the queen's made it
clear that she wants this dealt with
out of the public arena um she is trying
to put out the flames
in the wake of harry and megan going
nuclear
and possibly some might say that william
is just fueling the narrative i think
that's why
palace aids are now being told you know
no speaking to the media there are to be
no briefings
let's just let's just reign this in but
clearly
prince william felt that he had to say
something on this occasion he just
simply
couldn't stay silent and i think that's
an indication of how strongly he feels
how angry he is and how keen he is to
get that message out
this is not a racist family megan shared
with us that there was a conversation
with you
about archie's skin tone
what was that conversation that
conversation
i'm never going to share um but at the
time
at the time it was awkward i was a bit
shocked um
can you can you tell us what the
question was no i don't i'm not
comfortable with sharing that
we saw the queen reach out with yet
another olive branch to the sussexes in
that
short and very succinct statement um
that we were all waiting for this week
and i think it is very much the case
that she wants to
she wants to smooth things over and this
is not only being catastrophic for the
royal family in the public eye
don't forget behind closed palace doors
there are deep rifts that
are right at the heart of the royal
family
the queen is in her twilight years now
she's coming to the end of her reign
next year she celebrates
her platinum jubilee she wants to leave
the monarchy in a good
strong place the monarchy is all about
unity
and this fragmentation this this rupture
these riffs
at the center of it i'm not doing the
monarchy any good
so she wants to sort it out she wants to
see
her grandchildren she wants to see harry
she wants to see
her great-grandchildren and i think the
feeling is
that while she's going to be firm and
she's totally going to
investigate what was said in this
conversation this private conversation
she is also going to treat the sussexes
with kindness um i think she realizes
that
an angry prince harry can potentially be
quite a dangerous prince harry